ludivine de la rochère bonjour bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans la matinale de rtl france alors la
majorité présidentielle qui souhaite
donc une pma pour tout début juillet
avec un remboursement prévu de la
sécurité sociale pour plus d'égalité
finalement qu'est ce que vous dénoncez
avec la mise en place de cette pme
alors d'abord et avant tout le fait de
rendre volontairement des enfants
orphelins de père on va priver
définitivement pour toujours des enfants
d'un père aurait évidemment appel dans
la vie c'est extrêmement important que
ce soit pour le petit enfant le grand
enfant l'adolescent le jeune adulte que
sais-je et donc c'est une une injustice
terrible que de vouloir les primaires et
on crée une inégalité nouvelle je note
tout de même puisque nous parle
d'égalité bien là les enfants nés de pma
on peut les priver de pair au contraire
sciemment au contraire de tous les
enfants qui évidemment naissent d'un
homme et d'une femme c'est le cas de
tous mais certains et bien on pourrait
effacer leur père faire comme si il
avait uniquement une mère ou même deux
mères puisque cette loi elle prévoit ce
projet de loi prévoit aussi d'inscrire
son acte de naissance des enfants
concernés et bien qu'ils auraient
prétendument domaine donc on est
déconnecté du réel
on est dans l'idéologie la plus pure
alors là dans ce tournoi il ya bien
d'autres aspects de problématiques j'ai
lu ne te le jeu le on y reviendra mais
la bm à c'était donc une promesse du
président macron le texte revient à
l'assemblée après un long processus dans
les colonnes du jdd christophe castaner
salue ce temps long je vais le site et
la nuance permet l'acceptation des
projets sensibles vous lui répondez quoi
qu'il n'y a aucun consensus
il n'ya jamais consensus et il y en a de
moins en moins ils aient la paix parle
de processus
il a commencé avec des états généraux de
la bioéthique dont la conclusion dont le
bilan était que plus de 80% des
participants étaient opposés la pma son
père et 90% opposé à la gpa le
gouvernement l'exécutif n'a jamais
assumé et on sait pourquoi on voit bien
pourquoi de dire publiquement quelles
ont été les résultats
et maintenant c'est pas combien ils
utilisent les états généraux de la
bioéthique pour dire que tout le monde a
été consulté certes on a pu s'exprimer
mais rien n'a été été entendu il en est
de même du côté des philosophes des
pédopsychiatres et c est du côté du
sénat puisque le sénat à rejeter la pma
son père et que l'assemblée nationale
semble-t-il risque de la rajouter et de
la remettre dans le texte
donc en fait il n'y a aucun consensus et
les sondages montrent aussi qu'une très
large partie des français 85% des
français estiment que les enfants nés de
pma ont besoin d'un père et d'une mère
alors les donc ce sont les mensonges de
bout en bout
mais l'exécutif qui souligne un vrai
temps de réflexion et de débat vous le
soulignez les ces états généraux de la
bioéthique
selon vous où ils ont ils n'ont pas
permis la mise en place de ce débat la
mise en place d'un temps de dialogue
nécessaire
alors non seulement les états généraux
de la bioéthique ont été un moment on a
pu s'exprimer mais ce n'était pas un
départ il n'y a jamais eu aucun dialogue
ensuite dans tout le dans tout le
parcours du processus
eh bien on a eu on n'a pas été reçu
aucun opposant n'a été reçue à l'elysée
n'a été reçue par le ministre les pieds
verrou qui porte la partie sur la pma
son père et pour finir il ya eu cette
période de crise sanitaire qui a fait
que le débat démocratique et est
impossible jusqu'il ya peu et même
encore maintenant il ya des contraintes
très fortes
nous allons manifester ce soir 19h mais
il faudra s'arrêter un peu avant 21h à
cause du couvre-feu typiquement est donc
ce n'est pas vrai il n'ya pas eu de
débat est ce qui est extraordinaire avec
eux la macro ni c'est que ce temps long
qui n'a pas été un temps de débat il n'y
a eu aucun dialogue
aujourd'hui il le retourne pour dire ça
a été très longue donc on a dialogué
c'est faux il joue avec les mots ce sont
des sophismes en permanence au point que
nous avons déposé avec d'autres
associations et des juristes une
pétition sur le site de l'assemblée
nationale qui vise et qui demande aux
députés d'expliciter qui sont les
parents d'un enfant thomas loi parce
qu'évidemment et bien les parents d'un
enfant
ces normes
femme dont il est né c'est à dire qu'ils
sont son père et sa mère et on ne peut
pas prétendre que ce soit que cela
puisse être deux femmes ou deux hommes
que sais-je encore et donc on en est là
on en est a demandé aux députés de
redire et de ce qui est apprécié pendant
la loi mais on leur demande de revenir
dans cette pétition que les parents d'un
enfant c'est son père et sa mère
on en est à revenir aux basiques au sens
commun et à leur rappeler à la réalité
et j'invite en tout cas à signer cette
pétition sur l'action de pétitions de
l'assemblée nationale alors là vous
parlez de la pma qui est la mesure phare
de ce projet mais il ya beaucoup
d'autres questions sur la table je pense
notamment à celle des chimères
homme-animal par exemple vous rejeter en
totalité ce projet de loi ou alors il ya
des mesures que vous pourriez saluer
alors il ya une mesure qui est une
mesure complexe qui ne sera peut-être
pas celle qu'il faut pour tous les
enfants mais ils ont chois qui est la
levée de l'anonymat du don de gamètes
c'est à dire que désarmer un enfant qui
est né d'une pma -avec bien toner à 18
ans aura accès aux données non
identifiantes sur le lomu la femme dont
les gamètes ont été utilisé pour la
fécondation in vitro et il pourra
connaître son identité
alors donc ça vous le savez en précisant
à précisons que le conseil d'état sera
celui qui précise qu'on entend par
identité
ça n'est pas encore dit et d'autre part
pour les deux enfants qui n'ont pas de
père du tout ce n'est évidemment pas un
nom et un prénom qui rendra un père à
chaque enfant un dossier ne fait pas un
père ni même un nom et un prénom tout
seul mais on peut dire que cette mesure
est plutôt positif puisque dès lors
qu'un enfant c'est qu'il est né par pma
malgré tout il a besoin de savoir
d'avoir au moins quelques éléments et un
nom un prénom c'est mieux que rien et
c'est bien je pense que c'est une info
c'est pour les enfants nés de pma avec
tiers donneur pour le couple homme femme
mais pour le couple de femmes
ça ne rend pas un père à l'enfant il
aura toujours une absence complète de
pêche autour de lui et dans sa filiation
alors au moment du mariage pour tous
sont soumis
un million de personnes étaient
descendues dans les rues de paris à
votre appel aujourd'hui on a le
sentiment que tous ces français qui
était descendu à ce moment là ce sont
moins concernés par les sujets
bioéthique est ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous observez alors écoutez en
2019 en 2020
juste avant le premier confinement nous
avons fait des manifestations très
importantes dans les rues de paris
au point que les nous opposons prétendez
que les photos étaient truquées et le
cabinet occurrence a constaté que
c'était les manifs les plus importantes
depuis le début du quinquennat
seulement emmanuel macron quand même une
méthode très particulière qui est de ne
jamais jamais jamais dire aux français
ce qu'il est en train de faire avancer à
savoir la pma son père il n'en dit pas
un mot
et quand un président ou le gouvernement
ne dit rien d'un sujet c'est vrai qu'il
ya un peu moins de médiatisation et un
peu moins de relais mais né au moins il
ya énormément d'opposants et vous le
voyez à l'instant sur l'image 70% des
français auraient souhaité et trouverez
beaucoup plus sage de retirer ce projet
de loi est par ailleurs nous avons
pendant les confinements organisé
plusieurs fois une soixantaine de manif
partout en france au même moment mais
c'est vrai que le contexte que nous
connaissons ne nous a plus permis de
donner une très grande visibilité à
cette opposition ce dont emmanuel macron
profite
est ce que nous dénonçons ce projet de
loi ne devrait pas avancer là maintenant
tout de suite dans ce contexte de sortie
de crise sanitaire
oui on est pas des sujets plus
importants et plus prioritaires et
feeling évidemment jamais prioritaire de
prévoir de faire seulement des enfants
orphelins de père dans le projet de loi
de bioéthique il ya aussi la volonté de
créer des embryons humains génétiquement
modifiées ce qu'on appelle des embryons
transgéniques et des embryons chimères
animal hommes on à joindre et des
cellules embryonnaires humaines à des
animaux embryons ainsi que des gamins de
l'artificiel on voit bien que ce projet
de loi et dans la plus totale des
raisons il est purement idéologues et
par ailleurs entier que le gist et quand
on entend l'exécutif nous parler
d'écologie
verdir son quinquennat tenter plus le
fact et que en réalité il n'est pas du
tout dans un état d'esprit dès que le
gis global et de respect en particulier
évidemment de l'être humain
il n'est il va même à l'encontre de la
protection de l'espèce humaine
alors peut-être un dernier mot vous
défendez on l'a bien compris la manif
hortus le un schéma de la famille
traditionnelle
il ya quelques jours françois bayroux
alertèrent sur le peu de natalité la
baisse du taux de natalité en france
comment est ce qu est ce que vous
demandez à ce sujet au à l'exécutif pour
justement pallier à cette baisse de la
natalité
alors ce que je voudrais préciser juste
d'annoncer que ce que nous défendons
c'est le respect de la réalité de la
filiation humaines et les besoins des
droits de l'enfant après les aléas de la
vie fait que les enfants sont pas
toujours élevés par leur père et leur
mère est évidemment nous le savons où
nous en sommes conscients
donc c'est bien la fille sous le coeur
du coeur du sujet de la ferme à son père
et pour revenir à votre question
évidemment nous souhaitons qu'on est que
la politique familiale soit reconstruite
aujourd'hui elle a été démolie
il ya même plus d'allocations familiales
universelles on est complètement passé à
une politique sociale dans laquelle on
n'aide que les familles les plus pauvres
que les familles monoparentales etc
alors certes bien sûr il faut les aider
mais ce n'est pas pour autant il est
acceptable qu'on ait détruit des
monnaies la politique familiale
française c'est emmanuel macron a
continué à faire après françois hollande
et j'irai même au delà
nous devrons avoir une politique
familiale avec de nouveaux objectifs
avec des principes qui commence par
celui du respect de l'enfant
naturellement mais aussi qu'ils soient
plus dans l'anticipation des difficultés
que vivent les familles finalement en
france on n'atteint toujours que quand
c'est trop tard en vous voit bien en
france qu il ya une véritable crise de
la famille s'est constatée par des
sociologues depuis maintenant vingt ans
il y a urgence à reconstruire et même à
développer cette politique familiale
cette politique elle devrait avoir une
vue beaucoup plus large typiquement la
loi de bioéthique
elle ne devrait pas être prise en main
par un peu quelqu'un
un mini de la santé mais par un ministre
de la famille puisque l'enfant et le
coeur même de la famille et c'est sous
cet angle là on devrait considérer ce
genre de questions mais nous n'avons
même pas de ministre de la famille mme
hernandez lui devine de la rochère
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin je le rappelle vous êtes
présidente de la manif pour tous